Hey, what's going on is bill burr
and it is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh, I dunno when I think this is going
to be a special episode or maybe it's for
Monday. What would that be?
The 19th, I don't know what,
I'm a little out of sorts because I've
got to do a bunch of traveling this week.
A flat in New York. Come back and then
I'll let you bullshit. So, uh, anyways,
we have a special guest
every once in a while.
I take a break from rambling to
myself in my underwear there.
I'm at my house and um, you
know, drive my wife nuts.
So a this week we actually
have legendary drummer,
musician, human being from a Stevie
Ray Vaughan and double trouble.
Please welcome Mr Chris Latent.
What's going on, man? Hey Bill,
just hanging out in la.
I'm out here doing a project and um,
uh, again, awesome, right?
But I don't know if you're going to be
able to chew gum right up on the mic.
That curse. It'll drive people,
drive them nuts. Safe right there.
I'm already making you uncomfortable.
No, no, I'm good. I'm good.
Up until that more than several times
now. All right, well first of all,
what brings you out right now?
We are in our Los Angeles.
What brings you out here?
What are you working on?
I'm doing a project called the rides and
that's a band that we put together and
we did a project to the same
project about a year and a half ago.
The rides is myself, Bass
player, Kevin McCormick,
Lisbeth CSN and Jackson Brown.
And I'm very Goldberg, plays keys,
keyboards.
He was in the original electric flag.
I don't even know that. Mike
Bloomfield white back in the 60s. Um,
and then there's Kenny Wayne
Shepherd plays guitar and sings.
I saw you guys at the Greek you did this
summer. Yeah. That's absolutely ripped.
Yeah, he's ripping. Awesome.
What's it like to, uh,
Olin Stephens stills? He's in
there too. It was the other, yeah,
he's the last but not least.
And that's the band and
we're making a record and it,
this is your second one or you're the
first one? This is the second one. Yeah.
Second one that you got done is called
the rights. All right. D s right. Okay.
Now what, what type of music are we
looking at here? It's guitar driven.
It's blues. It's, you know, it's
original songs for the most part.
How do you, how do you know
why Steven Stills? Uh, well,
I know him through Kenny because I worked
with Kenny a lot and we go back many,
many years. Um, personally, I
know Steven is because of this.
I was asked, they talked about it
and asked me to join the whole idea.
What's that like? Just as, I
don't know if I, I, if, you know,
I played drums as a hobby and I'm
horrific. So I always wondered like,
I've always had unbelievable
admiration for a true musicians.
What is it that you do
you get that failing?
Like when you're sitting in the studio,
you're counting off a
song and you look on,
over at the side of Stephen Stills head.
Do you ever just think,
how the hell did I get here? Well, yeah, I
think that way about a lot of things. Um,
because, you know, growing up I was a huge
Stephen stills fan, Crosby, stills, Nash,
and young and right.
You know, Dallas Taylor,
who was the drummer in the
band way back when. I mean,
these are the things we're replacing our,
I've got my licks and I'll listen to
guitar sounds and songs and song writing.
I was like, awesome. It's like legendary.
Talk about legendary, you know,
and then you're,
and then I'm sitting there and I'm
looking over there and he's counting off a
song or having meat count off the som
going, wait a minute, how did I get here?
How do you stay calm in that moment?
Because I would sit there and I would
have like a resting face that you would
know that I was freaking out.
But inside of you, like, Oh, I
can breathe deeply and slowly
she wouldn't be here.
Now it's all good. You know?
I've had a long career,
so I've worked long and hard to get your
southern girl, you know, I deserve this,
I deserve it as well.
As much as I wouldn't deserve it,
but I'm grateful that I've got it.
That's awesome.
You can feel that because I've
never felt I deserve this. I,
unless it's something bad, like something
comes back to bite me in the ass.
I'm like, you know, I'm an asshole.
But like, I don't think I've, I've, uh,
I had a buddy of mine recently wanted
to go out and go buy himself a nice car
and I gave him a halftime speech
to go out and do it because a,
I'm trying to get my,
I got that,
that Catholic guilt thing where I can
buy my wife anything. But uh, but uh,
you know, if I was going to go by myself,
by the way, you pulled up in there? Yeah.
A Hemi, a Chrysler Hemi
station wagon. Yeah. Which I,
I've been trying to defend the station
wagon to my listeners. Most of them,
90% of them are not having it. This
is sports car bill. It's a sports car.
It is. No, but I like, it's
a sleeper. No, it is my mom,
my wife calls it to the thug car.
She goes,
he's going out in your thug car
to dance. Like, you know, um,
did you get the station wagon so you
can throw your drums in the back and all
that stuff? Yeah. You know what?
Every car that I get somehow is
motivated by that idea because you know,
you know, I do all
kinds of work, you know,
but it all comes down to the
very first work. I do this,
can I get my drums in the car?
Right.
And you'd get them easily at
a station wagon. Which shift?
What's your, your first,
uh, your first vehicle? You have a
head. The first one that I bought,
cause I know you're a big car guy,
you got to look a Shelby Mustang and,
and stuff like that
coming to blow your mind.
It was a Datsun five 10 station wagon.
Oh Jesus.
It's before they were called
Nissan over here. I remember that.
Dotson Dotson five 10,
you know,
it was a guy who does drag races with
one of those and he hits all electric of
seeing that then. And he was saying like,
it's a five, 10. I have seen that. Yeah,
that's that one where they started to
slope the back end and it's like they just
said, fuck it. We don't have enough time.
And they just sliced off the back
is not how it looks. Well, it was a,
it was a coupe or a a four door
sedan is what it was. Oh No, no,
five 10 what am I talking about?
I love that the five 10 we can build this
in the station wagon was in Tom p two
10 [inaudible]. Yeah, no, no,
no, no, no. Sorry. My mistake.
I'm still an acid.
Going to be times I said that I loved
that car and I can't and I'm so psyched
that I'm actually sitting here talking to
you like I'm freaking out a little bit.
You had to five tenants. Such a bad
ass car. Did you have the two door?
The four door? Well, I had the
station wagons. It was a four door.
You had a four a station.
Yeah.
All I ever did was put the key in
it and put gas in. I had the car for
like four years and it was,
you know,
it was when I moved to Austin from
Corpus Christi, Texas. I just said,
I'm out of here.
And I went to Austin,
I'll put all my stuff in that
car and I took off. And um,
how Lo, how old were you?
I was, uh, just turned
19. So 19 years old.
You gotta you gotta Datsun Five,
10,
four door station where you live in Corpus
Christi and you've been playing drums,
parent's house and that type of stuff,
listening to all these guys that
you eventually would play with. Yes.
And what happens you
basically as a musician,
because it fascinates me as a
comedian. Like when I started out, um,
you know,
it was all about getting on at Nick's
comedy stop and the Comedy Connection and
Dick is comedy club and
getting established there.
And then that becomes that moment where
you've done that and you dislike I now
what? Yeah. Now where do I go that that
must happen? Music musically too. Yeah.
You know,
it was,
I was in corpus and my father had died
and I looked around and I've been to
Austin to visit my sister who was a
university of Texas three or four years
earlier. And I woke up one day, I
was in music school in Corpus and um,
it's funny,
I just saw whiplash and I had this drum
instructor who I went in to take with
him cause he's one of the best guys and
rudimental middle playing. They said,
you're holding you sticks
wrong. I said, he said,
I want you to hold them traditional,
you know, military style setting.
I don't do that anymore. He said,
yeah, you're holding them wrong.
It was a French match grew up.
I said,
well Billy Cobham holds
his sticks like this.
And I had been doing that
right since I was a kid.
And just to let our listeners know, if
he ever watch like a drummer play, he,
does he pick them up the
way you naturally would?
Would she grab them both the same way
and then as that other way where the left
hand, if you're right handed drummer, it's
sort of lane sideways across your hand.
That's considered traditional.
The other's called match,
it's called mass group
and there's very styles.
But the thing was because
of marching drums, you know,
like in military operations, the other
drum hung to hang hung to the side.
So the stick hit perfect when
you held to the left hand. Right.
Cause the drum would hang to one side.
So you hold that hand held the stick
that way in the hand. That's, you know,
on the side of the groom, I mean the
other side. Okay. Anyway, so, and he says,
I see. So I don't care how Billy
Cobham holds his drum sticks. He goes,
you're not going to hold them that way.
I said, hey, you know what, I'm done.
And I got up and I walked out and
I woke up. No, I'm, I'm, you know,
I'm just sliding like whiplash. I'm just
sitting there watching the goods. Like,
Dude, you've got the talent. You don't
need to sit here and get yelled at.
I'm not saying it wasn't tremendous
performance by the guy from the insurance
commercials. What are they? I don't
know what his name is, but he's awesome.
He's awesome. Bump bump. But
it also goes to show you,
that's like that thing
with acting that you what?
Just UA handcuffed by the material.
Like if this guy doesn't get that script,
he just has to keep going. Like, uh,
whatever the hell he says in
those commercials. No, no.
So I get in my mock up the next day and
I go, you know what, I'm Outta here.
I'm going to Austin. And that place
was awesome. One of those, did you,
now did you say that to the teacher?
Not as he's screaming at you,
Michael Douglas and uh, no. Went back the
next day and I went to all my teachers.
I said, hey, I don't care
what you're going to do with
my grades. I'm Outta here.
And they go, when you leave, and I
go right now, leave the building.
I got the car packed and I'm on my way.
Do
whatever you want to have my grades
or any of that stuff. I got to go now.
What now will you always like
that sort of strong person?
Because I think if I was 19 years old and
if some guy like the dude and whiplash
said, you know, the holding your sticks
wrong, I would be like, oh, okay.
And then when as he yelled
at me, I'd be like, you're
right. I know I am. Well Shit,
you said, we touched on this a
minute ago when you said that,
because when I said I deserve
this, like, oh, did I say that?
Because I've been trying to work over my
Catholic guilt too, you know. Um, so I,
you know,
sometimes I go,
I deserve way more than I got and I
don't really deserve with anything that I
even have that pendulum swings done.
Swing is wide these days.
So that's the good news.
But not always kind of been defiant in
a contrarion and a bunch of other stuff
with some good stuff. But um, no,
that was easy because something
told me you need to get outta here.
There's something for you there
that you're not gonna find.
A lot of people feel that, but
they don't act on it. Like I,
I do both. Like I have times where I have
this feeling, I'm just like, what, dude?
Fuck you.
I'm out of here.
And then I have other times where
that voice is screaming at me,
waking me up at night. I'm grinding my
teeth and I still like ignore it. Like I,
I could not, I'm not, this
year's the first year, um,
this year we're three weeks into it.
I mean,
in the last year I've really started to
listen to my gut and if I meet somebody
and my, despite what they're doing and
all their accolades and everything,
if my gut has that feeling of like,
do this, this isn't right, I, I've,
I've walked away from it. And two of the
things that it really came back like,
wow, man, I was, I was right on that one.
So it took me almost 50 years
to figure that out. But, uh,
so I'm always like, uh, drawn to
stories like that. So then you, you,
you leave, you say fuck that
these two, the whiplash guy. Yeah.
So I got,
you know,
it's funny you said that because I mean
kind of aren't we like that? I'll go the,
the,
the best thing that I can do is when I
had that intuition that's attached to
some kind of passion to actually
listen to that as opposed to, God,
I fucked that up. I better do something
different. That's a big turning point.
Right? And that's what
happened. Right? Then I went,
I don't know why I'm going there.
All I know is that something
tells me that I need to go there.
So it took the 200 bucks.
I had my pocket for peace drum kit in
about six changes of clothes and I just
took off and drove there.
So you drive and then you show up.
I always try to encourage people who
listened to this podcast to, you know,
if it's not the wrong with being
in a cubicle and doing that,
but if you don't want to do it,
you have this thing telling you to
throw six shirts into a car and drive
somewhere that you should do it. Um, so
you, when you show up, you have no way to,
and this is the big questions people
always have when it comes to following a
dream is like, then they're always like,
and then what? And it's kind of like,
what would you say? He just figure
it out as you get there. Yeah.
You know the thing that you have to keep
working and you don't give up and you
follow that intuition,
you pass some common sense
and pay attention to the
things right in front of you.
I go, you mostly think some work out? I
mean, they work out one way or the other.
So how long did you sleep in your
car for? Well, I didn't this,
see there were some guys
that had, that had a band up in Austin.
They live in this little shack outside,
a little town called Maine or Texas.
It was fifth 14 miles outside Austin.
They said they'd just come back a
few weeks earlier. They get, yeah,
we abandoned the place and they go, it's
got the rest of the rent paid. I went,
can I get the key to that joint? Okay.
That's some of those deals where you go,
Huh, I can maybe use that if you want
to give it to me if it's rent's paid.
So I went there and it was outside and I
had nothing. I was sitting there going,
get now what? You know firstly what the
rent was paid for, how long? 14 days.
That was paid for like another couple of
weeks. And I had some guys who said, hey,
why don't we go up there?
Let's go up there.
So the idea was that we were going to,
we were going to have a balanced as it
come on up there. I'm going, let's go.
We can have their old house and Blah.
So we did that. Nobody had anything.
And we kind of sat around and p jammed
in the, in the, in the house, you know,
we didn't really ever do
anything except that. Meanwhile,
when the guy went and got
a job and another guy went
and got a job and you know,
I had the only car,
I drove a guy to his job and he picked,
he covered my rent the next month
because we were out there for a couple of
months. Right. Um, you know, the
story could get really long. No, no,
no. This is all fascinating. What, what
kind of kid were you playing at that time?
I had a Gretsch Kit. You did an a four
piece Gretsch kit. What do you play now?
You lead with gay? Well, I play
Ludwig on a play fives. I played both.
I played both of them. Oh,
okay. I was a Ludwig Guy.
My very first kid I played was Ludwig,
Ludwig and Zildjian, which was basically,
that was the Cadillac of back
then before all these, uh,
for the Japanese companies. And uh,
yeah. You know, I mean, Mitch Mitchell,
I heard that and well, what's he doing? I,
and I saw a picture, I'm like, yeah man,
you know that's right. Because we was
the top and over there. What was it?
Premiered drums over in England. Premiere
England. Yeah, he played those two books.
Premiere. Right. You know, and then there
was Yamaha and parole, all the work.
And you know,
we're around for a while,
but when the like everything else they
finally got here. Right. You know?
So how long before you got into an actual
situation after you moved to Austin
that you were in a band, you guys were
playing in the clubs, you could eat and a,
you could make your rent.
That was two years later.
Two years later now will you one of
those guys we did you just like as far as
like other musicians
seeing you and being like,
I want to play with this guy or that's
the kind of guy because the drums or the
foundation,
did you have a style that that,
did you have to go out and
shake a bunch of hands?
Are you one of those guys that sat down
and play it and people just like that
guy can play. Well, here's what
happened. One of the guys that came back,
it came up later, it can be in that
band. And then immediately, you know,
we know it didn't have a band,
was a sax player. He lives here.
Joe Sublett looser in La and
he got a Gig with a, with a,
with a band called Paul Ryan,
the cobras.
And there was another band called
grease the wheels who were looking for a
drummer and I didn't really have a Gig.
And he said,
you ought to check out my roommate.
He's really good.
So I went and auditioned a much with
a bunch of other guys and they said,
you got the Gig. That's where I started
making a steady paycheck paper on Friday.
You know, right now because you needed
that gig where you extra nervous.
It's one of your first gigs.
So, you know, I mean more,
more nervous than I was just to begin
with about live. But you know, I'm,
the only thing was that
one of those things,
because you were always playing
with other people that you,
you didn't feel the nerves. You
know what? Well not, I mean, I,
I mean I'd still do now you're talking
about looking over at Stephen stills
aren't going like shit, you know, let
me get the right field. This like, no,
it's this way. It's every day. And I was
like a, you know, that's a daily thing.
Like, you know, I look for something
that helps call me, you know,
it keeps me in the moment,
you know?
But you have those moments where
you stepping out on stage Guy Shit,
I hope I do good. You know, and I will
do. I know I got it. I don't know.
Maybe I can yeah. About
whatever. We haven't gotten
lost in a song. Hopefully like,
no, I don't mean in a good
way. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. I
do this show, I do this show.
It's called the goddamn comedy jam.
It's a really cool thing.
It's funny you went romantic.
Yes. All the time. No, it's true.
I've met like, like, so
what happens? Basically it,
he knows a lot of comedians like myself
that play instruments and you know,
wish that they had your abilities
on whatever instruments. And uh,
we ended up becoming comedians.
So Scott [inaudible] and Myers,
he has this comedy show where you go up,
you do 10,
15 minutes and tell stories about going
to conscious and then you go back,
you jam with the band, either play guitar,
you sing, he played drums. So I, uh,
I've done it like three times,
did it last night.
And sometimes I find myself so
listening to the bass player,
so I stay on time. I forget,
I'm not listening to the lyrics.
And like this song we played last night,
the chorus went around twice the first
time and only went around once before.
I went to the bridge a second time. And
I'm literally in the middle of it going,
is this the first time or the
second time we played this?
Has that happened to you? Well,
yeah, but you know what, you're,
you know that here's the thing
is after enough experience,
and Stevie's to say that she said,
if we just make our ears
real big and pay attention,
we have the tools and we'll be all right.
And while he bought her find about that,
not what I find that
about that as a ratio.
The other thing is I can really be
front running the deal. Right. You know,
it's no different than, you
know, quarterback who's he's
taking the snap and the,
and the receivers already down the,
down the field and he's
throwing the ball or you go,
the guy's not down there
yet. Right. You know,
so when the guy gets down there
and I'll see what's going on,
then you act in the moment. And that's,
I mean, that's really what, what I do,
everything's about living in them in the,
in the incident.
And if you're listening to everybody,
unless nobody knows what's going on,
you'll all do it together or whatever
it is, we'll be fine. And if it's not,
you go back and retool and figure
out what you did wrong together.
What's the worst example you have of
like being up on a bandstand and nobody
knew what was going on and they're all
looking back at you like what he had,
did it all just fall down the stairs
there? Do you want me to hold the fake it,
we started this Hendricks story.
I do these tours. I wish, man,
I wish this could I just
seeing the look on your face.
You like this 600 yards staring Islam.
Uh Ah.
Okay. Yeah, we had thinking about,
I was thinking the first thing
that came to my mind, I do,
I'm the drummer for the experience Hendrix
tours, which I played with everybody,
right?
That's like three hours long.
And we did this one tour that started
in DC and the idea was, you know,
everybody knows Jimmy Hendrix songs and
we'll just all show up and you know,
and we go, we got this, we got this in
her employment, these guys and what,
how does he do it and does he do it
the same way, you know, whatever.
And so we go out there, they're
sold out houses. Like, as this,
I'm counting off the song, guys are
going to buy keys sitting on, you know,
like you gotta be kidding me. Oh No.
It's like train wreck after train wreck.
And they're not only looking
at me, but you know, I'm going,
I thought this is where it goes to
the, the chorus. But how come you're,
what do you do?
You know,
they're looking at me and I'm looking
at them and you know, this whole thing,
it's like everybody's up there
with their pants down, you know,
and everybody in the audience, how
many people are watching 4,000. Oh,
Jayson. And they're like,
with their mouths open going,
I pay $250 for the seat.
What are y'all doing up there? You know,
and it's just like mayhem. I'm going to,
uh, you know, I know
how many gigs, I mean,
I imagine after that you guys just said
immediately went to the practice room.
We work that out. Well, yeah, but yeah,
but then, but then you're on the tour,
so it's like your gig and every day.
And so you used the catch as
catch can sound check. Hey,
let's get together in this room.
Let me show you what I was thinking about
that on that song. And you know, for me,
I'm listening to everybody cause
there was, hey, let's do this. Hey,
let's don't do that. I'm going, okay,
let me keep it straight because then
a few hours we're going to go hit.
And how long did it take for you guys to,
to whip that into shape? I don't know,
eight or nine years. That's a
work in progress. But I mean,
to the point that people in the crowd,
novices weren't noticing the look of
panic or be it in the wrong key and oh,
it took us a few shows. But you know,
that's the thing. It becomes personal.
You know, you do your work and you do
something. I don't know if that, you know,
sometimes that's funny. And you got, it
could have been funnier. I, and you know,
it could be better, but the thing
about me is I'm up to it by myself. So,
even if I'm falling off the rails,
whatever direction I decided to go
into to, uh, to try and right the ship,
it's 100% of the performance up
there are going in that direction.
So at least it looks good cause it's
just me. So whatever decision I make,
it's not like I'm looking
at the bass player and he,
he goes left and I go right.
And the whole thing falls down. Like
I've, I've always been amazed at,
but let me get back to,
cause you already brought up Stevie,
I know there's listeners going like they
want to hear those stories. So anyways,
so two years in you get, um, you get a,
you getting a pay check and all
that. You, you, you're working in 21,
22 at that point, 20 years
old. So here's what, you know,
2020 almost 21 my roommate
says he got to come out,
see our band, you know, I said, yeah,
yeah, but I've been working all the time.
So it was a Tuesday night
and I went out to go see him.
And this is interesting because when I
walked up to a place called Soak Creek
saloon and it was a big
old frame house then got,
and it was just a club out
in the country and I walk up,
I hear the Mamet man's house,
grandma and I heard this guitar town that
wasn't any louder than the rest of the
band through the wall,
but I could hear it like it was like
right there in my ear. I'm a tough one.
Is that?
Yeah.
And I walked through the door
and I turn and my guy go, right.
My eyes went right to Stevie on with that
guy is fascinating and I was seeing a
lot of people, but I'm went,
there's something about this guy.
I go out the next lap,
I go out the next week and to go see
him again because I'm really digging the
band and their late and my roommate turns
to the guys and when to get my mom to
get my, why don't we get my
roommate up here? He goes,
really good drum the gang and then
I'll sweat for Rodney. So some more,
a little more time goes mom, places
packing the God, God get him up here.
So I get up there and I play like four
songs with them and I'll look over and
Steve, he's kind of looking over shoulder,
kind of giving me the wink, you know,
and the very next day, nice.
He comes over to the apartment,
he walks in on me and I'm playing along
to this Donny Hathaway live record.
Everything is everything. Willie
Weeks and Freddie Wyatt and I'm like,
it all settled,
look up,
but he's like standing like four inches
from me and it startled me. Went, no man,
go ahead. Oh Man. He goes, what? Donny
Hathaway. Huh? I go, yeah, he goes,
ask one of my favorite records.
So we started chatting and
I tell him, I said, man,
I love to work with you. So I think
that we could do some great stuff.
What was it like that, that first
time when you played those four songs?
I know you've taken in the whole band.
I know. It's just like, all right,
the next drama is going to show up.
I don't know how that works,
if he's going to be upset that
you weren't as drums or whatever,
but where you still had that
feeling as Stevie's playing? I mean,
I didn't know what was the context
of the band? Was there a singer?
Was Stevie singing and was,
was he just a considered like a side man?
Guitar player?
He was a side of me and kind of featured
Solos and he's saying like he's saying
a song. There was two guitar players,
there was a bass player, a drummer,
singer, solo singer, um, and a sax
player. Then my friend, my roommate,
Joe sublet. Okay. And where,
where was Stevie's playing at that point
was very r and B, like, you know, he'd,
he'd come from Dallas and
his brother Jimmy had really,
when he heard Jimmy played guitar,
thought maybe ought to do right.
So he was thinking, I was like, you know,
it was like Freddie King and uh, you know,
Eddie Taylor, Jimmy Reed and slim Harpo
and a bunch of BB king. Freddy was,
was his playing at the
level at that point already.
We like this guy is going to be
one of the greats of all time.
Well you know what, he was just
fabulous anyway. You know what I mean?
But he wasn't as out front and,
and grandiose is the
really the wrong word.
I know you can do anything he
wanted to do, but he what he did,
he could play one note and he went,
that's the coolest note I've ever heard.
He's just going back home,
you know,
and just had it or recordings of
him when he was like 12 years old.
And he was like, when he was, he sounded
like Eric Clapton cause he was like,
you know, because yeah, he was
playing Eric Clapton looks like a,
that sounds like Eric Club goes
ceviche 12, you know, so it's like,
so he could just say, you know
what, I hated that. It's like,
just pick anything up and sound fabulous.
Know I know that God so did,
um,
so then he's standing there and like,
so at that point,
I mean it's weird because he's just
a guy named Stevie, Stevie Vaughn,
Stevie Vaughn at that point.
Okay. And this is probably like,
what are we talking at this point?
Mid Seventies, late seventies is 19.
This is like late, early 1977, 77.
So he's still wearing like that
sort of that big skully cap.
He didn't have in bowling
shirts and you know,
Brogan shoes and you know,
pleated pants and stuff. So at,
so at that point when he,
uh, he says, um, you know,
that that's one of his favorite records.
So where did it go from there? Well,
he left. Um, the two, fast forward some,
a woman living on Barton
is a singer in Texas,
pulled him out of the cobras to start
a band called triple threat review.
That lasted like five or six months and
then it blew apart and it turned into
double trouble.
And that's when I came in.
He asked me to say we want to
play in our band. So in, in a,
in a fast evolution, you
know, eventually ended up,
it was Stevie and myself
and Tommy Shannon. I mean,
there's stories of all this,
but you know, but that became
the trio that, you know,
that speaks in that light.
The front.
I know you've probably
answered this a zillion times,
but what was that like the first time
you guys all got together in a room when
it was just the three of you and there
was all that space now Stevie to play?
Well, that's when his guitar plan started
changing because he was, you know,
he's mean to me is a musical genius.
And then he followed
that intuition perfectly.
The thing we were just talking
about and that he went,
he knew that he couldn't
be in a trio format,
he couldn't be just a rhythm and
rhythm and Blues Guitar Player.
So he immediately,
he started incorporating solos and
rhythm all into one kind of thing,
which sounded like two
or three guitar players,
like a four or five piece band and
three with three guys. And he was,
now he was singing because he was singing
all the songs and he develops quickly.
You know, his thing
developed very, very quickly.
So now we kind of start stepping out.
But the,
the part of the reason that we went from
a five piece band with three piece band
is that some have said Manyatta
do like a Jimmy Hendrix tune.
So we did I that guys sounds
like Hendrix and then everyone.
So the first one you guys did,
we did,
well we did voted child and we did
it forever. We did at our whole life.
But we did, you know, we'd,
we'd do a gig every once in a while
where we do all Hendricks Stub,
manic depression and hey Joe and,
and uh, you know, it has been,
everybody else in the band was like,
don't play that shit. You know,
we're a blues band, you know, and it
just kind of, the rub came to, became a,
a wedge has really kind of what happened
on the musical side of all that was, oh,
was that like a Texas Blues
purists saying, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't do that shit around
here. You know, we played blues,
played appropriately and there's
a lot of great traditional,
a great upholding of tradition in
Texas till lots of different things.
But you know,
we were the ones that were like,
we were in the white kind of a little bit
outcast cause like if we're doing this
wild shit, we're playing too
loud playing Jimi Hendrix songs.
We started doing superstition by Stevie
wonder cause we discovered we were big
fans of all these people and people
like yeah, no it's blues and,
and and I'm thinking I must have been
exciting for you because just sitting in
with a blues band after
a while is a drummer.
I mean that can get monotonous is
trying to play it like a how many,
how many different ways
can you play a shuffle?
And I'm sure you could say a thousand
but I'm just saying just sitting in with
the like I never,
I've ever,
I mean it's ridiculous that I'm even
trying to relate to you on this level,
but anytime I've sat in and when people
start playing blues at Bomp Bomp bomp
dump on and you just sit in back then
it's like I want to kill myself after one
and a half songs. You might need
to examine that more deeply.
You know what? It's funny because
I tell people, they go, hey,
you know this and that
about your Microsoft
only know like four beats.
But I know a lot of different ways
to play the same four beats. I mean,
and shuffles or like endless.
And that's what's actually
beautiful about them to me.
And I didn't know this until I started
doing that and somebody said, hey man,
check this out. I mean, out on the spot.
Right. You know, metaphorically, you know?
And they went, no, no, no, no, no, no,
you're going cooking. Good con cocoon.
But it's really Putin, Pataki, Pataki
platoon. I was like, Gah Gah, Gah,
Gah, Gah, Gah. Oh Wow. It's like
endless varieties. Like it's like,
how do you make a stew? It's like, Nah,
it's meat and potatoes and care. So yeah.
What about all the other shit in between
that makes it something really great or
something like just fucking meat
and potatoes and carrots, you know?
And that's kind of that simple really,
or that complex or the only way I
can compare that to what I do is,
uh, I guess if you take a joke
and you can just do the joke,
you can just stand there and say it.
You can act it out.
You can have two characters in it talking
and you can end up basically taking
something that was essentially a shit
joke. Oh, Riddick joke or whatever.
And you can, you can actually
flesh it out into a piece,
which I guess I don't know what,
there's really no definitions and comedies
like when it makes a bit what makes a
piece, but you can, you can have
a little performance piece, um,
out of that. And uh, I've always,
I've just had such an admiration
for them for like musicians,
your guys' ability to, uh,
like I don't feel like,
like what I do as far as this like talking
and that type does everybody talks.
So it's kind of like your
jam and all day with people.
So you can immediately think
something and then say it.
The fact that you guys can do
that musically, like sonically.
Think of think of Phil or think a lick
and then just as you're thinking it,
play it the way. If I thought it,
whatever words I'm saying right now,
I mean to me like that is,
is is when you like really master like a,
an instrument or something like that.
You know what's funny?
When I saw your show in Austin, you came
out talking about the, about dogs balls,
you know?
Yeah.
He's cutting up balls off and I
thought that's funny as shit. And I go,
that's true. You know, we got a dog and my
wife, so we got to get him fixed. I went,
can we let him have him tear off one piece
before it? She's like, no, no, no, no,
but I'm thinking about it.
You said it and I actually related to
that skit to somebody else and they're
like, so what's the deal? I was like, it
was funny as shit when he said it. Yeah.
That's like when I tried to play is
now Chris plays it. It sounds awesome.
Now it's like fuck.
Gives you the chills when I play,
it makes people go shadow off.
Oh God.
How much longer you have playing
like all, all of that stuff. So, uh,
so you Tommy and Stevie play
and then eventually, uh Huh.
So how long did you do jam
for? Like I know like, um,
I know I'm going through all this shit.
I'm,
I'm getting self conscious here that
I'm dragging you through the same. Nah,
that's okay. I haven't, you know,
I'm going to try to ask
different questions and
everybody knows the story that
David Bowie stuff and all of that,
you know, David Bowie's, you actually,
would you mind telling the getting booed
and France thing just because people
know me for getting booed and Philly? No.
Ugh. Yeah. Got to tell you this. This was
Larry's cause the woman Lou Ann Barton,
I have to say it,
we fired her for the band for misconduct,
if you will.
And she gets a big record deal
from Jerry Wexler. Wait, wait,
where was she in the band? She was, yeah,
she was originally in double trouble for
just a little bit and she was the lead
singer. She's saying most
all of the material. Okay.
So she's out of the band.
She gets a deal with Jerry Wexler,
discovers her in New York, gets her
deal on Electra. She does this records,
get the muscle shoals rhythm section.
Uh, Don Frye sings all these,
all of these people come in. So went to
a record release comes to be, she goes,
she goes, you guys want to play my
record release party? I was like,
yeah, you let her go. Yeah, no, not right.
She didn't, did she do it out of spite
you think, you know? Hell, I don't know.
You know, maybe I could call
her and ask her, but um,
but were there playing and Jerry Wexler's
there and he's like out there dancing
and he says, great
band. Um, you know what?
You guys need to go to
Montreux Switzerland. He goes,
I'm going to call my friend Claude nobs.
I'm going to talk to him about all this.
Well, he does it short over a couple of
days later, we get an invitation to go.
I got a spot. We never been signed.
That kid was in Switzerland.
It wasn't in France now. Yeah, it was
Montreux Switzerland. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
All these years I thought it was
friends and, well, here we go. Okay.
So we go and we're the only electric band
on this night because he just slotted
us in because there was a time slot
and it's a jazz festival. Well,
you know [inaudible], he's speaking
Montreaux jazz. And if they come,
they'll call it international
music festivals.
It's kind of a mix of a lot of stuff. But
that night was all like Acoustic Blues,
upright and piano and guitar sitting
on stools and that kind of thing.
Traditional, traditional,
there's that word again.
We get up coming back to haunt you guys
to haunt us against. So we get up there,
we got all these electric instruments
and stuff and we start playing.
And people were like, you
think like, they're like,
they're sitting in a hurricane
or something. And they're
like, I think a pool,
you know, was like, and
we're like, shit, we plan.
I've seen that you can actually get
this on DVD. And, yeah, no it's,
and it's a bummer because, see where,
but birdwalk in Texas making like three,
four or $500 a gig and our man,
the owners of our management group
loaned us 15 grand to do this whole trip.
We mean we took everything over there
cause we can't be without our gear,
you know. Wow. Um, and we're,
we're sitting backstage and
Stevie looks at me, he goes, well,
I didn't think we sounded that bad.
I don't want, I didn't hate her.
And though it sounds like, yeah.
And they go, Eh, David Bell,
he would like to meet with you.
Ahmet which David Bowie.
And they went the Mr. David Bowie, the
accountant, the rockstars. David Bowie.
The wrestler. Yeah. And so
that's kind of how that started.
We were there another night. We played
downstairs, we didn't have a Gig,
we were just lolly gagging on this loan.
And so we, we play down in the musicians.
Bart's with Jackson Brown and
his guys came through and he say,
you're ever in La, you can
have my studio, which we did.
We just recorded some tapes and you know,
all this,
there was a whole bunch to the story,
but they just kind of sat there until we,
back to John Hammond said, hey,
Stevie's looking to do this thing,
but we got these tapes that we recorded
a legitimate types and he's in,
John Hammond was our, he was our, our
white knight. He was our champion.
He loved all of us.
He loved the band.
He thought Steve was one of the greatest
guitar players you've heard since
Robert Johnson. Wow. And he
went to, he went to epic, Sony,
epic, cvs. He is me. And there was a
guy there, Greg Geller, he said, Greg,
you need to sign these guys up. And
they said, yeah, I'll do it. He goes,
I'm getting ready to get fired anyway
because I'm going to reissue the whole
okay label cause it's been
out of circulation. They're
gonna fire me for that.
So I'll let them also far me for this.
And he did that and that's what happened.
And the record came
out. And, um, you know,
Stevie didn't go work with
Bowie after the record,
didn't do the tour and off
we were, you know, now you,
what I loved about that whole,
that whole watching
the concert footage of you guys when you
get booed there in Switzerland for all
these years,
I thought it was France,
is the fact that you could
see it affecting you guys.
Cause you guys would play the song and
then an end, the bu or whatever they,
they boo. And then,
but then when you guys,
you guys come one time he saw Stevie
shoulders kind of slump a little bit,
but the second he goes to do a song,
you count off the song you guys played.
You didn't hold back at all and he just
went just as hard. All you guys, uh,
if you didn't hear this,
that does the sound of the crowd,
you would think that the way you
guys were playing, that you would,
doing what you always did,
which was, was kill it.
And I got a lot of inspiration out of,
out of watching that I'm just doing
what I do or are auditioning herself.
You know the,
sometimes I get these acting gigs,
I got to do some crazy stuff that I'm
sitting there and you had going like,
oh my God, this is outside my comfort
zone. And like seeing stuff like that,
it's just like,
just plow through this.
Um, fuck them. You know what,
that was inspirational to me because I
learned something there and I saw it in
action. It wasn't told to me is that
he had this passion and commitment.
He was sitting over there on the couch
playing the guitar or he'd have, he put,
he put the same thing into it as he is.
He would if we were playing for over
100,000 people because that's just how he
lived. And I'm like, man, that's a great
example. You know, cause like, yeah,
I kind of do this. I'm going to
see when the stakes get higher.
I'll kind of put a little bit more juice
into that kind of wishy washy and as he
was like full on 110% all the time.
So when you guys are riding on a tour bus,
when he's noodling around,
it sounds like he's already
playing the show. Yeah,
because he's got the same passion and
the focus and the commitment to what he's
doing as he's not
performing. You know? I mean,
he's not jumping to been incredible
to be as awesome as, I mean, you know,
like I was spoiled right off the bat.
You know, it's like I go, you know,
this is early in my career and I was 20
I talked to Mitch Mitchell about this,
about the, you know, the death
of Jimmy Hendrickson is like,
it's a hard deal when you lose somebody
like that and you, you were, you come to,
in my case, I came to go, you know, I was
grateful that I had the whole experience.
I think it was a hard thing to lose,
but there were so many
things that I got from that.
Just simple lessons and you know, I
think they were in me, they'd been,
they'd been demonstrated but
they hadn't really taken root.
But when you live them and you got,
man,
this is a great way to be and you see
that you get the result on every level.
We're talking about money,
success.
Our success was that our
music was successful to us.
It meant everything to us.
We had a great time doing it
together and that you just go,
this is it's self evident
right now and you know,
and somebody leads that typically
somebody is there to show you something.
You Go, wow, you know what,
I dig that, that touch me.
That meant something and I'm going
to grab onto that and that's,
these are the great things in life.
And then unfortunately you
don't really fully know
realize it after they just,
this the profoundness of losing somebody.
I lost a great friend of Patrice O'Neal
a few years ago and he was the guy like
I would compare like he was like Stevie
Ray Vaughan level guy accepted when like
stand up and um, you know,
you just don't expect him.
He was like 41 years old.
You're not thinking that this is going
to be the last time I get to see him
perform and, and that type of
thing. So it ends up having a,
when you really go back and examine
the whole x basically experienced,
because I don't know if
Stevie was the same thing,
like being friends with Patrice
was beyond being friends with them.
It was like it you,
you walked out in public with him
and him just messing with people.
Was this experience that like I,
I,
I've tried to tell the stories on the
podcast and try to explain what it was
like. You just can't, when
you're around that level of, uh,
artists or just,
just greatness.
I know their words
where there on for Zena.
But that's that thing that you don't know
what you got until it's gone. You know?
It's Cliche as hell, but it's
true. You know? That's why
it sticks. It's like, man,
that was fabulous.
Yeah. I learned that awful
lesson that like, you're like
your friends, that's like,
I can't explain that the
friendship is not yours. It's like,
it's like this thing that's given to you
and you just have to enjoy it and then
you got to be enjoying it because it's
just taken away or it goes in a different
direction, whatever you want to say. And
then you just kind of left there like,
you know,
well, you know, living in the moment,
being able to actually live in the moment,
I don't know,
to be grateful for your surroundings
cause we can get you don't get on my pity
party and all this shit and go back to
my Catholic guilt and shame and all like,
ah, you know, you know, and I mean
it's true. I mean Stevie, I was like,
when after he died I was like, God,
that guy really meant a lot in my life.
And I go half the time I
wanted to strangle him and
I go, we were like brothers,
like the Bro, you know, he was like a
brother. I never had, he had a brother,
you know, a real brother and, but I
go, you know, it was, it's everything.
It's always everything.
There's the, our, our,
our perception of the good
and the bad or whatever it is.
But essentially it's like I go,
everything was wonderful.
It was life and it was really wonderful.
I always wondered like, that's the time,
like, you know, the loneliness
of being a comedian on the road.
But whenever I hear stories of yeah,
hands, you know, being in a van
together, just traveling and,
and you know, just all the
shit that you guys go through.
Like I've traveled with other
comedians and stuff and there's like,
there's that thing where you just have
to, after a while it'd be like, okay,
this is going to be, the guy is going
to be the addict. There's going to be,
the Pussy Hound is going
to be the ego maniac.
The dude who's got to sleep til four,
like there's just going to be the end.
You got to understand that
you're that guy somehow,
but you can't see it
because you're in yourself.
So you're slowly something you are
doing that is annoying the shit out of
somebody else. And you have to somehow,
uh, like I gotta be honest with you,
like after a year, so of touring
with other comics and everything.
This past year I did a tour with
this comic Paul Versey and, um,
he's a New York guy. I'm a Boston guy.
What else? You always argue sports.
And we went up to,
uh,
toward all of Canada and we basically
spent every waking moment essentially with
each other for about 10 days.
And we never argued once and all I,
it was just through years of being,
he's also a really easy guy to get
along with, but we just, we had it,
we ended up having a couple
of inside jokes that we had,
which always seems bands always have
like inside jokes and you're on catch
phrases and we just kind of tore
through Canada making each other laugh,
uh, throughout the whole thing. And,
uh, and it wasn't until the end,
he actually first he actually mentioned,
he's like, dude, do you realize we've,
we've been,
we've done like 20 shows together,
taught all over this God Damn Tundra.
We haven't argued once. And I was, ah,
you know,
I didn't even notice that we're doing
this stupid fake crying thing that was
just making each other laugh.
Just saying over the top sensitive stuff.
Like I just really liked he was a
friend. Oh, it's that dumb shit. Oh,
we had all that stuff. Just kept
you going. Then you have the wheel.
We had like these alternate
personalities when we,
when we realized that we were like really
going insane on each other. You know,
mom was Harold as, oh, he called
me and I would watch hell would do.
And I go, I don't know what you
do and Brady in the Brady Boyd,
you should trying to have a
good Tom, you know, and we get,
and we would actually stay
in these characters for like
an hour. I'm going, God,
how sick Arlene.
And then we come out of them.
We could actually live with
our circumstances because
you know, it gets tight.
You know, you're there. You realize like
not only is that genius comedically,
that's also if I had some sodas,
you know, psychology background,
that's also probably red flags of slowly
going insane. No, I am insane. I'm,
I'm, I think I've been actually somewhat
restored to sanity, but you know,
I'm still working on it. Right. That all
goes to the seven deadly sins, you know,
and tried to sort it out over
your bill. Oh, I know. Jesus.
Don't even talk to me
about those. What, what is,
what's the longest time you
ever spent out on tour? Oh,
shout because you guys like people
always to say to Comedians, hey,
you're doing a tour a year on
tour. And it's like, you know,
the most I'll ever be gone as a
week and a half, maybe two weeks.
But you guys lets it. Yeah.
Gotcha. And all I gotta do,
all they gotta do is, yeah, let's
deal with the insanity, my own mind.
I don't have to deal with other people's,
like once you kind of figure yourself out,
you know,
when you can kind of see
what demons you give into.
And of course you got to ride that for
a while and keep fucking up and running
to the brick wall.
But then hopefully you grow from it.
You can kind of manage your
own a little bit, but you
guys like, I mean how many
fucking bands out there I did,
they broke up and then they needed to
get back together for money and they get
back together from money and within six
months they go right back to where they
were emotionally 30 years earlier.
And I got a whole thing on
that but I won't get into that.
But to answer your question,
um,
we never came off the road and using
double trouble isn't the answer to the
question. You know, when Texas flood
came out and we started touring,
we were like for nine years
we virtually never came home.
I mean I'd go out for it,
we'd go out for like two months.
I come home for like four days and go
to Europe for like five weeks and kill
like a week. How do you pay your bills?
How do you pay your taxes? You know,
while I had a business manager and
account and I've got a great wife at home,
I've been married for 29 years and she
kept the whole household together and she
was all right with you being on guns. I
think she's know she'd be like, uh, great,
your home. And then like a few days and
she goes, when are you leaving again?
You know, I'm like, no, it was good. That
was awesome. My wife, she'll be like,
can you be doing stand up tonight?
Yeah.
Usually when there's a TV show on that
she wants to watch and I sit down and I
can't keep my mouth shut. I'm literally
like a five year old and I sit down. I,
I'm either going to be making noise,
doing something or I'm going
to be talking to the TV,
like it's a person and uh, like,
I don't know. Do you find like,
do you get like scatterbrained if you
go on the road too long and you finally
get, can't like shut it
off? Oh, well yeah. I mean,
it happens both ways for me because when
I come home, you know, like she said,
I was just talking to her, my wife
Betty, she said she's, you know,
it's apparently been nice since
you've been gone, you know,
and you know what she says that with
all the love and are hard because I get
home and I'm like bouncing all
over the place and she's, you know,
everybody gets their own life.
Everybody has their own. I see.
Like you run back into the house and
they're like, Hey, I'm home. And they go,
oh hang on a minute. Yeah. Then
a different vibe going on here.
Since you've been gone let you try to
like assimilate back into the general
culture, you know, other than it's my
kingdom and I'm busting it, you know,
so no, I get it. You know, since I
mean it works, you know, you don't,
you know what I've always,
I think instinctively know that I've
needed to have with my house is I need a
room over the garage. And I feel like
when I come home and it's almost like,
you know,
if you have like the Benz except you're
coming off the rose and they just send
you into that room and you got a TV,
you've got something to work out,
like an elliptical machine,
just something and you gotta like
just slowly ease your way back into
civilization. Bill, I'm not
one, I highly recommend that.
That very thing you just described.
It works pretty well.
Well let's hear about it.
What isn't it?
Well I've got another house in
Austin and I've got my studio there,
so I go over there and do my thing when
I'm referring to at least have a place
in the country outside of Austin had a
guest house studio that was about 150
feet from the main house.
So when I come back I'd go over there.
That's where did all my workout at a
pool outside now go swim and you know,
do my thing. So that kind of
like go there, go to the house,
stay there or go to the,
you know,
it was right to not just kind of like,
just be like a truck busting through
the wall coming home. I know strangers,
that's your own damn house. I know
that's my take on it. You know,
you could hear the other side to
see if it go he's full of Shit.
That's not how it worked. But if
that's how I saw it and that's what I,
that's how I used it.
Well let me,
I'm going to ask you a couple of
questions here. See what we get.
We got left here, cruising along here.
Um, so maybe a couple break it up for you.
Some non musical questions.
Cause I'm sure obviously
people have actually the same
damn questions I've asked
you. Uh, I saw this thing in the news.
My listeners were asking me about it.
There's this billionaire is getting
a divorce, right? He married,
he married this woman.
He had a company,
it was worth like 50 million
bucks in a oil company.
They've been together for 20
something years. They get a divorce.
He writes her a check for
just under a billion dollars.
Who was 990 something million or
980 something million, something,
something in like 31 cents,
something crazy. They had worked out.
He writes her the check,
the check for almost a billion dollars
and she turned it down. Who says, I don't,
I don't know from Texas. They might be,
they might be. Her thing is that he's,
his company's worth 20 million bucks
now and she's only getting $1 billion.
She's entitled to more because she helped
support him through all of those years.
What, what, what, what is your,
uh, he got rubbing your head.
What is your take on that?
Oh,
I had a friend who got divorced when Tom
and he said, God dangit. He goes, my wife,
he goes, you know what? Here's, here's
the deal. He goes, she goes, she told me,
she goes,
what's,
what's your hours is mine and what's
mine is mine and what's yours is mine and
maybe more so like, oh, I
don't know. I mean, what,
why did they think I wish I should
have had a female on this? Like,
why do they like,
you know what I feel when I look at that
thing that is not even about money. No,
it's not.
It's,
it's like Kevin Spacey's thing on House
of cards when he turns towards the
camera and he says sex is about
everything other than sex. You know,
y'all are going, it's not really a dye
can't put dollars and cents on a really.
But when all that deep,
they want you to feel pain.
And the thing about it,
you know what I think this guide that I
think the reason why she didn't take big
take that money is because that
guy fucked up. First of all,
they showed the check on TV cause
eventually she cashed it because she had,
she needs money to live,
which is hilarious. Um,
it's like you've got enough money to
live 10 20 lifestyles the way Mc hammer
lived. Yeah. He could actually, she
could actually save Oakland, um,
with that kind of money. But
he, uh, she, this dude just,
he wrote it on like a personal,
it wasn't even like on like a being like
a business checks, a little bit longer,
bigger sums.
This guy took it out on just like some
regular like eat the same checkbook if
you live in let's two week,
that's insulting a little.
And that's what he did.
And he wrote her name and just went
scribble, scribble, scribble a tear.
Here you go. And I imagined she walked
out and was just like, wait a minute.
So that's it. So I get it. I
mean, I know I've got $1 billion.
This motherfucker has billion dollars.
He's
all this shit.
He's ugly.
But with that money he's going to be
able to get himself a hot piece that will
at least pretend to like him.
He's got enough money for
every Ferrari on the planet.
I was like another billion
coming down the road to me. Yeah.
Like this guy is not going to
feel any sort of pain whatsoever.
I'm not okay with that.
So everybody is watching this going,
this woman is a gold digging whores and I,
I think it has to do,
not a whore gold digger, but like I
think it has to do more with a emotion.
Yeah, we lost everything. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I, that's, I mean,
I don't know anything other
than if my wife divorced me,
I guess she's been by me for a years ago
and I mean, if it was something like,
you know, Hell hath no fury like a woman
scorned. I don't know what the guy did.
I don't know anything about any of
that. But I go, if she felt really like,
like I had done something to go, she like,
Hey, I've been here for years, you know,
supporting this thing. Right.
You know, that's my time.
I can only speak to my own
personal experience. I had never,
and I'm not in divorce, I'm happily
married and thank God for that.
I'm grateful that I am. But you know, I
don't know. I mean, you know, I don't,
I don't know what all
that means other than,
than feelings have no real
pressure on them. Or they do.
Maybe they do and it's not enough.
You know,
he should have let her down easy or God,
he should've just fake cried
as he was riding it. Be just,
he should have shown some sort
of pain and he didn't, uh,
he probably sat with his eyebrows up and
you know, looking through. It was dumb.
Reading glasses. How much you watch. I'll
throw in another million. There you go.
All right sweetheart. See you.
That's what I don't know. Yeah,
it's great that you've been married
for how long? 29 years. 29 years.
That's amazing. Can you pay you just to
keep it going? Yeah. Yeah. So far so good.
I did bring you something cause I thought
bill is going to want to talk about
football. So I got you a little cookie
today. I know. We are actually a,
I gotta check to study. Got
me Cook because he knows that
I bake. I know. Yeah. No,
that's that thing too. Yeah. Oh
it's the shape of a little football.
But Mike, we got to get a picture
of this. I got to tell you,
this is the most adorable thing
another man has ever gone.
Larry, are you a big football
fan? No. You brought, no,
that's why I brought you the
cookie because they'll thought,
and I actually broached the subject.
I go, you know I'm, I've been,
I'm a Green Bay fan. She says,
people in Texas here, there,
I liked green bay because they're
owned by the people in Green Bay.
I love that idea. That's a great
answer. I love that answer. I love that.
It's not the billionaire that
cause I'm going to buy me my,
my own team or whatever. That's
fine too. But I love that.
I breakfast her one morning and the fry
cooks like, yeah, I own like a share.
I was like, right on man. He goes, I'm
a route and forum going. I love that.
But how does that work? He owns
a share, but it's not like a,
they call them up and be like, how much
money should we give Aaron Rodgers?
I only know says this. I
Dunno. I Dunno, but saw, yeah,
he might want to talk about
football and you know,
I love a good football game as much as
anybody because I was at Starbucks and
I'll look down, I saw the football
cooking ware. That's for Bill Burr.
I'm going to get him a cookie.
You're always going with your gut.
This is ridiculous, man. I can't believe
that you're doing my podcast. And he goes,
you brought me a cookie and then
you brought me, uh, you know, I,
last time I saw you when you were
playing the Greek Kenny Wayne Shepherd a,
I brought you my uh,
my Carnegie Hall Album,
which you guys played, right?
Hey, you guys bought the
Mariachi suits. That's the,
I know a little bit about your band,
but I think I'm going to give him that
suit to the rock and roll hall of fame
because we just got inducted.
We're going Stevie Ray Vaughan and double
trouble or being stuck right this year.
And they called about some stuff.
I thought I was thinking about the,
you get that suit that I played it.
I had made Jesus that took
them long enough on it. It's
beyond me. I don't know.
You know what we did?
We stopped doing that.
We see what we were doing 25 years ago and
somebody said, hey, guess what? I'll go,
the people did it. The people who
vote in the, in the, in the, in the,
the general public gave us 18 and a half
million votes. If you talked to Tommy,
do you guys think, yeah, you
guys going to play when you,
and yet we're going to play. Who, uh,
who are you going to get to sit in?
That's secret.
Now we don't know where it's,
we're still kind of sorting all that
out. We don't know. Exactly, seriously.
You know,
you guys had the respect of everybody.
So I would think that all the usual
suspects that you guys played for and then
some, there's some suspicious people
out there. Hey, I got that GME. Yes,
Eric. Well, there's all, you know, we
know we, we know all these people. And so,
you know, when I would think there's
all these younger players, yeah,
I would want to John Mayer and
those guys would want to come. Uh,
I bet you would think just
a test testament to the
music that you guys put out.
Um, they would all want to play
with you. So what do I got here?
So I was just mentioning that
I gave you my, uh, on vinyl,
my album from a Carnegie hall.
Now you brought me Stevie Ray Vaughan
and double trouble trouble, uh,
Texas hurricane. This looks like there's
like 10 records and you know, well,
let me tell you why. Look set me.
Tell you why that's so big. Um,
it's funny because I had, I saw that sit
in my studio and you gave me that vinyl.
I'm uh, yeah, I'm just,
I'm going to take that to him
because of what we've talked about.
And that right there is a 200 gram vinyl
of are the definitive box set that's,
those are 45 rpm disk.
So it doesn't get any better than
that unless she were in the studio,
which they're all 45. No, no. It's a no,
it's a regular 12 inch like an album,
but it spins it 45 rpm. That's why
there's so much so many disks in there.
Oh my God. Now, so what does that do?
Does that make the sound quality? Yeah,
it's better than 33 and a third.
I love this as this is shit cause I don't
know any of that. No. You know what?
You put that on your stereo in, in,
in whatever you liked about our music.
It, there's no way that it can sound
any better than what's in that box.
And that's for sale. I mean that's
that. We just came out with that.
You can get those wherever,
wherever they,
where you can buy vinyl or
acoustic sounds and Salina, Kansas,
you can get the suboxone and
33 and a third or 45 rpm.
The 45 rpm is like the cream of
the crop. All right, so I gotta I
got, I'm going to go out on a limb
here and say that this is going to be a
collector's item at some point. I can't
believe that you gave this to me minutes.
All I gave you was I didn't pay much
for it. Only blood, sweat do I gave you,
I gave you a bunch of Shit and
Dick Jokes on a record. High Man.
Exquisite sound by the way.
I want it to be a comedian.
When I was a kid I wanted to
be a comedian. Is that right?
Yeah. People said, well,
you're already a smart ass.
Maybe you can actually say something
intelligent and turn that into, you know,
real comedy that you go, Oh, did you
like when you were growing up? Oh,
well you know, let's talk
comedy here, Chris. Well, you
know, I like Richard Pryor.
Love Jonathan Winters. Did you ever get
to see prior in concert? No, I didn't.
Did you see Jonathan Winters?
No. I saw him on TV and you know,
the tapes and whatnot. George Carlin.
George Carlin was like heavy. Yeah.
Um, yeah, he was probably the most, uh,
and I don't know,
I'm trying to think of anybody that
was more prolific as far as it did.
It did stand up like all these guys
now who are just putting out special,
special, special man. I'm
trying to do it too was a,
that's all he was the one that showed
that that was possible. That every two,
three years, you know, you could, I mean,
you can't come up with an hour like his
button. I mean, it was possible to have a,
a at least an hour that was special
worthy, that was worthy of being, uh,
recorded. Um, I dunno man, like,
uh, that guy for me was, you know,
for me it was always,
it was prior Carlin Cosby Kinison.
Uh, then all those older guys that
I watched with my dad foster Brooks,
Martin and Lewis Shecky
Greene election fuck up.
You know who I loved that I stumbled
upon. Um, over the Christmas break. You,
have you ever seen a, it's a mad, mad,
mad, mad world. Yes. Long time ago. Yeah.
I, that's one of my favorite movies and
every once in a while I got to own that
thing for some reason I don't own it.
And I saw a,
I watched it and there's a guy in there,
this comedian,
Dick Shawn addiction on nine.
Dick Shawn plays the guy that he thinks
somebody is doing something bad to his
mother and he's driving,
he's trying to,
he's trying to catch Milton Berle and
there's a clip of him that just when he's
dancing with this woman and just the
over the top emotion of him. And uh,
I watched some of his standup and he was
really kind of ahead of his time with
like the physicality,
the repeating and like the cadence,
the way he performed his stuff.
And it kind of from when I was
able to read up on the guy,
he was like a comic's comic, never quite
hit the, uh, the mainstream. And uh,
had a really crazy, uh, when he died,
he actually died on stage
doing a gig down, uh,
one of the colleges down in San Diego
and he's literally on stage and you know,
he was doing a bunch of physical stuff,
making people laugh. And then he had a,
he had a heart attack,
did like a face plant and he's just
lying there and people feel like three
minutes. That was part of
the act. It sounds like a
drummer death certain oh yeah,
yeah. I'm under a number of
drivers of diet on stage.
You thought there's a reason for that?
Oh, I don't know, man. Got Shot, you know,
I know there's a good shot on stage.
I'll he got shot up. No, no, no, no,
no. Um, I thought he got shit
done. No, no, no, no. Sorry.
Okay.
Oh, now I'm confused on, into the memory
banks. No, there was nothing there. Um,
he sounded like me right now.
No, I'm so serious. Like, Oh,
who got shot and who just
died of a heart attack? Um,
a guy in Canada play with a
friend of mine. He did die
in the middle of the show.
He turned around, he said, he said,
hey, come on man. Pick up the beat.
And the guy kept slowing down. All of
a sudden everything came crashing down.
The guy like just died. Oh God.
Was he a big guy? He was a big guy,
but he fell into the drum kit and it,
he hit the guy in the back of the legs.
All of a sudden there was no music come
who got shot on stage was the comedian
and the lugs that death go
out. I'll laugh. Something,
you know, that's an age falling into
a drum. Kits are always fun I guess,
unless you don't get back up.
But uh,
I don't know why I spun
it in that direction,
but basically the guy was laying
there and people yell, no, you know,
take his wallet thinking he was
just joking with the guy was yeah,
it was literally dying right in
front of them. So, all right,
so I slogged you through all your old
stuff. You were a sport about it. What's,
uh, what do you got? You got the
Stevens still thing coming up, but we,
where can we see, where can people
see you live? The man that, uh,
hadn't knows an endless
way to play a shuffle.
You know what I should tell
it should have had that ready.
I didn't know you'd ask that. I'm
going to be done. So it's funny,
all great artists never know where the,
where they're going to be.
The worst promoters ever.
So good.
If you're a hack coming in here
and I swear to God you would have,
you'd have it all.
You would,
you would have handed me a one sheet of
all the bullet points that you wanted to
hit a, I'm telling you, well,
lump bullet it out. Do you have,
do you have an idea of when
you're touring again? Yeah. Well,
there's something to do.
A few shows in,
in early February out here with Kenny
Wayne Shepherd over going to be in the
southern, the La area. I think
we're doing a Gora. Okay. Uh,
the Canyon Club are doing, who's that?
Who's that? That keyboard player young.
But he looked like Burton young.
That was hilarious.
One with somebody called me up in the,
and I listened to that and I was like,
his name is Riley Osborne.
Riley Osborne,
greatest keyboard player I ever saw him.
He's awesome.
I call him the Humphrey Bogart of
piano. I mean, he's like, yeah. Yeah.
Who said that about me? I said, Bill
Barry goes, it was a Fox that I go,
he's a comedian. He goes Murray Young. He
was, I guess I kind of do look like him.
Oh God, I already pissed the guy. I
just waste, he's pissed off anyway,
so it's okay. When I love was when
he was his time to take a solo.
Just how he just went in so many
different just effortlessly. It just I,
I don't know, just watching
you. One of my favorite thing,
not only to watch a great musician is the,
that extra added that he makes
it look like he's not even,
they're not even trying and I was
watching you the way you will play in the
shuffle and just the whole thing that
you were doing like just always been a
trans fixed.
Some of the stuff that I loved,
wish I could hear you play more as like
the some of the jazz drum he did on
stank swaying and that type of thing.
It's like you really had
and what was great. That was
all the licks that you had,
knowing that you had those in the bag,
but you played for the song
on a lot of those other ones.
We just played straight and sit back and
let Stevie, you know, run with it. It was,
I don't know, I've just tremendous amount
of respect for you, uh, as a musician.
And now as I'm starting to get to know
you obviously as a person and I hope that
I'm going to be able to get
out to Austin this year.
I might be going out there and March for
south by southwest to promote the all
things comedy network here and a,
if you're around,
if you'd like to come out to the
show, uh, you know, come on down.
The only stipulation is you got to bring
your Shelby. I want to see it. Okay.
That can be arranged because I'd be done.
All right. All right. But everybody,
Monday morning podcast, uh, with
special guests, legendary drummer,
Chris late and thank you for listening.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next time.
All right. Hey, you didn't
go anywhere, did you?
I'm still here with Chris late
and I forgot to bring something.
And this is the first Monday
morning podcast epilogue,
just like the old streets of
San Francisco. Uh, you also
brought me a jar of Lard,
pure pork leaf lard. Keep
refrigerated. What is this a,
what is behind this? I brought it to
you because I saw your pie crust. Oh,
it did? Yeah. Yeah. And, and, and
the track, the old school train,
the trick of, of, of, of
pastry. And I, you know,
and I've done this a couple of times,
but somebody as a chef steel,
you take butter and mix that in with it.
When you make your pie crust and you
can fry fried chicken in it or whatever,
you know, it's awesome. And this
is called Dai de Doo. It's dyed Ui.
It's a group in Austin with chefs
and stuff. Who processed. Do Di do a,
or as I say, de do Dai
due, I'm such a moron.
Butcher shop and supper club. And let
me give him a shout out here. Two,
four zero six manor
road, Austin, Texas. Um,
and it's Daya do.com so people could
actually order some of their large, yeah,
highly recommended. Highly
recommend, highly recommended lard.
A while I'll shit, well, I got
a tour of Australia coming up,
but when I get back I'm going to keep
this refrigerated and I'll definitely, uh,
I'll give it a shot. Um, no, I'm,
I'm all about the butter and lard thing.
All right. There you go. There you go.
A little more information diet. Do Butcher
shop and supper club. Jesus Christ.
Next time I see you, I got to bring
you a little gift bag. I saw stuff.
I'll figure out what the hell you
are renting. All right. Once again,
Chris late and everybody, thank you
for listening. Thanks bill. Bye.